Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David
Pakman show. I am David Pakman. If
there were a cloning experiment
that went terribly, terribly wrong.
Let's talk a little bit more today about Heather
McDonald and the right wing obsession with race
and racism and not the way that they project
on the left about being all your obsession.
Everything's about race. Everything's about race
in the way that they want to make white Christian
nationalism the order of the day for the country.
And a lot of people push back. When I say that,
when I say that the Republican Party is the
largest white supremacy organization on the
planet. I stand behind it. Yesterday, Charlie Kirk
had a woman named Heather McDonald on his show.
And I want to get you a little acquainted with
this regular Fox News guest, Heather McDonald,
a woman who is a tireless defender of police. No
matter what they do, no matter what news comes
out, no matter what video is made public.
Tireless defender of police. These are some
headlines. Are media matters put together from
her? Various. Just a few. By the way, not not
all of them. Just a smattering of headlines of
quotes from her appearances with Tucker Carlson,
the host of Fox News's Evening White Supremacy
Fireside Chat. Teaching diversity curriculum
in schools will destroy any possibility of
further civilisational advance. We should
not be bringing more black children into this
country. If Democrats think America is racist,
police are forced to arrest black men at
higher rates. Quote By the facts of the
crime. And finally, good law abiding
blacks are calling for the abolishment
of police. Leave it to the aging white lady to
tell you what good law abiding blacks are doing.
Well, she was on with Charlie Kirk, the Twitchy
Zeppelin headed freak over at Turning Point USA,
another verging on very dangerous character. And
they were having a conversation about policing,
you know, after the release of the beating of
Tyree Nichols. It is now on the lips of every
conservative in the country, either making excuses
for or outright denying that there was a problem
with it. And Charlie Kirk makes an assertion
that is is and has been and will continue to
be a legitimate white supremacist talking point.
Many of you know that my my wife, my co-host and
my partner in content creation, Brittany Page, was
raised in a virulent white supremacist household.
We talk all the time about this normalization
of white supremacy and white nationalism in
the country. Things that she grew up with only
whispered about in private are now on the public
agenda. They are now on the docket for Republicans
to get advanced as policy in the United States.
And because of that, it is normalized clips like
you're getting ready to see of Charlie Cook. Watch
this. The four years I've been told by activists
that blacks commit they don't commit more crimes.
But the reason they might and the statistics is
because there's more police in their neighborhood
is the exact opposite of a way to view it.
There's more police in your neighborhoods
because blacks commit more crimes. Period.
Speaker 2: It's like, you know, we always
hear about, well, riots are caused by the police
showing up in riot gear and that causes everybody
riot. No, it exists. As you say, it's the exact
opposite causality. The reason the police are
there in riot gear is you guys are rioting.
If you don't want the police in riot gear,
how about you stay home and or protest
peacefully and don't start throwing
Molotov cocktails at police precincts? Yep.
Speaker 1: Yep. He says smugly. One. Charlie,
just a little bit of advice. Maybe get a bigger
shirt collar. I know you only have like a 14 and a
half inch neck, but that collar is doing a lot.
Speaker 2: Of work.
Speaker 1: To stay buttoned.
Neither here nor there, though
the assertion that blacks commit more
there's more police in your neighborhood
because blacks commit more crime is
just virulently racist. Openly racist.
And then the clip continues, because then
they just they're breaking their own arms,
patting themselves on the back about all of
the contributions that Western culture has
provided and denigrating third world countries
as having done nothing for the world. It's all,
again, part and parcel pattern and practice.
Standard operating procedure for virulent,
sinister white supremacists. Watch this.
Speaker 2: Do you have heads of art museums
saying the Western tradition 5000 years of art
is racist because there weren't black sculptures
in fifth century B.C.? Athens Well, there were no
blacks. And that's. Yeah, but they're willing to
tell people. They're willing to tell young people
coming to museums for the first time see this
collection through the lens of racial exclusion,
which is poison. Yes, classical music heads are
also saying, oh, the reason that there were no
black composers in in 15th century Flanders is
racism. No, the demographically Europe was white
until the 20th century. So that is heartbreaking.
But yes, up to a point. You're right that the the
elite white perpetrators of racial preferences,
when it comes to their own immediate
lives, do expect that merit will will
triumph. On the other hand, for their own
institutions, corporations are mandating that
managers get promoted based on their own hiring
of blacks and promotion of blacks, and are setting
just preposterous hiring standards that can't
possibly be met given the academic skills gap.
I mean, the it doesn't matter. What about 10.
Speaker 1: Seconds? Sorry. Sorry, Heather,
we're up against a break, but we're going
to have you back and just close the point.
Show me anything from the third world that.
Speaker 3: Is as beautiful as Beethoven's Fifth.
Speaker 1: You can't. Some things are more
beautiful than others, however. Thank you so much.
Some things are more beautiful than others.
Show me something from the Third world that's
more beautiful than Beethoven's Fifth.
You can't, he proclaims arrogantly.
This is white privilege run amok. This
is two people glad handing one another
while trafficking in white supremacy.
And this is mainstream Republicanism
like it's never been before. Obviously, racism has
been a creeper in Republican politics for decades.
We witnessed it with the with the Southern
strategy and how how how it gained a foothold.
When Reagan announced his campaign,
a Californian announced his run for
presidency in the eighties in Mississippi.
And now it's taken a foothold. It's gross.